you guys have been on like carpets
together and is it true that Mila Kunis
is like you guys like need to get
together more and like put your arms
around each other like Mila texted us
the other day she goes you guys look so
awkward on the carpet together wait is
this true what that's because you you
guys you're so weird you act like you're
like kids at a like at a birthday party
you don't want to take pictures or
something well somebody's like married I
feel really weird about touching them
yeah I mean we're really good friends
but we're like I don't know what people
want what what is it supposed to be like
that
I don't I don't get it like